je suis curieux
je suis kirill cerebronikov je suis au
festival du film de khan et c'est vraiment cool que la
femme de notre film tchaikovsky aime le fermier
du chikovsky soit en compétition [
Musique]
genre d'histoire passionnante complexe et intéressante
sur l'amour et la passion par le
façon c'est une histoire d'obsession l'histoire
d'énormes ego qui se battent les uns contre les autres des
gens qui ne se comprennent pas
et cela a
conduit à la vraie tragédie
[Musique]
vous travaillez normalement travaillez sur le film comme
quelques années
et si nous faisons ça  film bien sûr, il a une
valeur particulière pour nous, il est vraiment
important de raconter l'histoire qui n'est pas
bien connue du
public et ce
sera probablement un défi et excitant pour
le public ainsi que
pour nous pendant que nous le faisions
[Musique]
depuis mon enfance qui appartient à l'
union soviétique je connais le phénomène
qu'on appelle le cinéma français et regarde toutes les
femmes de l'union soviétique euh
adoré alain de long
john gaban
les hommes étaient plutôt amoureux des
grandes actrices françaises catherine dinov
et moi  Je suis un vrai fan d'Isabel tu associes
Isabelle salut le
cinéma c'est une politique c'est ce n'est rien d'autre
qu'une question de politique parce que c'est du cinéma
c'est une énorme déclaration sur ce en quoi nous
croyons vraiment
[Musique]
je ne pense pas à moi et dans
tous ces termes  comme
la pression du risque dissident j'essaie juste de faire
ce que j'ai à faire
[Musique]
pour que les jeunes lisent les livres
et regardent des films ouais en passant pour
regarder les films
merci beaucoup